donald trump jr made a big splash this
weekend tweeting that he trusts trusts
podcast host comedian and mma
commentator joe rogan more
than he trusts dr anthony fauci
who heads up the nih
is the top infectious disease doctor in
the united states has spent his career
working on infectious disease
now of course this comes at no surprise
that junior trusts rogan more than
fouchy not shocking
but sadly it's emblematic of a bigger
problem in the united states and you
might say yeah david it's called
stupidity yeah i know i know but i i'm
gonna speak a little more specifically
when it comes to authority and expertise
there is now a particular problem in the
united states
there is a logical fallacy called the
appeal to authority appeal to authority
is a fallacy
where one
claims something must be true
because
it comes from someone believed to be an
authority on that subject now you might
say well authorities on subjects are
more trustworthy that's exactly the
point i'm going to get to that as i've
said before
a little bit of knowledge can be a
dangerous thing and now that these
radical zealots heard about the appeal
to authority fallacy or they might not
even know that's what it's called but
just experts don't know everything okay
they are often quick to say
experts smexperts
that's an appeal to authority fallacy
now of course there are two important
details about the appeal to authority
fallacy first of all it's only a fallacy
if you claim that something must be true
only on the basis of a certain person
saying it that then it is a fallacy it
might still be true but it is the
fallacy
secondly
if someone is actually an authority on
the subject matter
it's not a fallacy
unless again it's the idea that only on
that basis of it being believed that
someone is an expert so
given to put it away that makes more
sense
given two competing hypotheses about
some phenomenon
one from an actual expert a real expert
and one from a layperson
absent some specific reason an
evidentiary reason to believe the expert
is wrong
airing on the side of thinking the
actual expert
maybe the one who's right here is not a
fallacy that's different than the appeal
to authority fallacy and this is
unfortunately incredibly common right
now on covet
the actual experts
are written off by a misunderstanding of
this fallacy now there's another problem
here
the same ignorant people who
misunderstand this fallacy will often
reverse it
and they will end up saying
this doctor has the right view
on kovid and it's a doctor so you've got
to trust them and then you'll look and
it'll be like scott atlas a radiologist
who knows nothing about infectious
disease or it's a chiropractor which
it's a type of doctor
but it's not an md and it's certainly
not an expert in infectious disease
so that's one layer to this
before i get to the other layer
it is
ironic maybe more like disgusting
that the right loves to criticize when
when they know what it's called the
right loves to criticize
the post-modern attitudes of some on the
left that everyone's opinion is valid
all perspectives must be allowed
and on and on something i disagree with
but the right loves to caricature all
the left as believing that
and here they are doing a version of it
which is saying well
you've got an infectious disease doctor
okay well that's one thing and then
you've got i don't know podcast host
that's another it is valid
for me to say i trust the comedian more
than i trust the doctor now of course
don jr is allowed to say it but when
they say there's an empirical reality
and that's what's so wrong
with this perspective on the left this
post-modernist perspective of it's all
valid listen
well
if you're going to be critical of that
then you have to be able to look inward
and say i'm kind of doing the same thing
here when i say no no no
we must allow
rogan's view to be just as valid from an
evidentiary standpoint as dr fauci's
they will never
look look look within themselves they
will never do that now let's get to the
second kind of uh
problem here
the same ignorant people
who um uh uh
so we've talked about layer one which is
junior says he trusts rogan more than
fouchy okay so that's like one layer
the same false authority applies to don
jr weighing in on this and what i mean
by that is
there are people in this country
who will also trust joe rogan over
fouchy
because joe because uh don jr said it
okay so that this is like a second layer
it's like concatenated
expert confusion or like russian dolls
you know those matryoshka dolls one goes
inside the other of expertise confusion
don jr
misanalyzes the expertise of rogan
versus fauci on covid
and then others in turn
misanalyze don jr's expertise
on identifying who's more trustworthy on
covid and that's where it really gets
ugly so to make an analogy
imagine i don't know see he would never
do this but imagine sam cedar said i
trust pacman more than rogan on mma
well sam misunderstanding expertise
because i don't know a damn thing about
mma and joe rogan does but then
trusting sam
to ascertain
whether i or joe rogan know more about
mma is that second layer and that's what
we're talking about and unfortunately
the trump family looked upon almost like
deities by many in this country and they
are immediately taken to the idea that
well if don jr has assessed
that rogan is more trustworthy than
fouchy
then that's good enough for me you get
it bottom line is
we're in real trouble that's essentially
the takeaway here
there are so many interesting new types
of assets in which you can invest at
this point there are sneakers there's
wine there's artwork and so many others
but the big question is which of these
makes sense as investments and that's
why i am such a big fan of alternative
assets which is one of our sponsors
alternative assets is a newsletter it's
a newsletter that will help demystify
these different investment markets
whether you're talking about video games
or sports cards
music rights comic books and the like
alternative assets is doing the analysis
about each of these different
asset types they do extremely deep
research and give very valuable insights
into them but alternative assets is not
just about
information it's also about results and
they have recommendations with an
excellent track record which you can
check out and learn more about on their
website
ton of smart new ways to diversify right
now it really is a different era when it
comes to investing and alternative
assets makes it very very easy to
understand
go and sign up for free the link is down
below